okay if you've got college loan payments
you're going to have to start paying
them again that pandemic freeze gets
lifted later this month and when that
happens students need to plan how
they're going to resume making those
payments mary jane belligesa joining us
live with some options that they may
have when it comes handling all that
college loan debt mary jane good morning
good morning to you john and heather
while there's always the chance that the
payment freeze might be extended again
like in years past borrowers should plan
to start making regular loan payments
starting september 1st advisors from the
scholarship point it's a program helping
students plan and pay for college says
student loan services will be contacting
you about payment soon and there's
plenty of options for federal student
loan repayments you should start
evaluating your options now as there are
eligibility requirements for each
repayment option if you can start saving
money now to make transitioning to
payments much easier
if they haven't contacted you yet you
have you should reach out to them to
figure out what that payment is going to
look for you
going forward and it's been certainly
two and a half years so you might want
to start budgeting into your monthly
plan during covet they did have a
forbearance and all of
my friends that did consolidate
with a lower interest rate through the
banks or any other company
they had to apply it was like a big
process so i was actually really
thankful at that time that they were
willing to work with me
if your student loan provider hasn't
contacted you yet you should reach out
to guarantee you won't miss a payment
before the student forbearance ends and
right now that student loan forbearance
is extended through august 31st of this
year reporting live in the newsroom mary
jane ballaza live local now you've had
two years you've got to plan ahead of
course but now he's now you really got
to be prepared i know i've gotten a lot
of time next